this mock-up is pretty similar to the
portfolio mock-up you worked on in the
previous lesson there are some
differences however for example the
layout of the work examples and the
color scheme particularly that of the
background you can see the colors and
the hex codes on the left side of the
screen but you should always start with
looking at the design and as always
consider the structure it should be
pretty similar for this mock-up because
it's so similar to the one you already
did despite the fact that you don't know
anything about bootstrap yet you can get
started with the new web page now that
you've got the design mock-up which
steps can you complete now can you
create a folder structure for the
projects can you create a Dom tree for
the page
can you write HTML that defines the Dom
can you assign class names to HTML
elements can you write CSS and can you
test the page check all that apply